65 long days and still counting since
joe biden broke his promise to the
american people abandoned our fellow
citizens our friends and their families
all behind enemy lines and now breaking
tonight the state department's inspector
general is launching multiple
investigations into joe biden's botched
withdrawal of afghanistan now many in
the media they have moved on joe biden
has turned the page
we are not doing the same now the deep
state always protects their own not
really counting that much on the
investigation time will tell
we have much more abiding disastrous
foreign policy throughout the show
including the fact that our own
intelligence community had no idea and
were totally completely and utterly
shocked by the military might a china
with their new hypersonic weapon and
we'll give you the details but first a
message about joe biden and covert 19.
unlike many in the media mob we're not
going to politicize a global pandemic
we're not going to try and score
political points or use scare tactics or
distort reality as always we try to give
you the facts encourage you to do your
own research take it seriously consult
with the scientific expert look at your
unique medical history current condition
talk to your doctor and or doctors and
also encourage you to draw your own
conclusions based on an informed
position not joe biden remember in 2020
he used the global pandemic as a
political wedge all through 2020 on the
campaign trail he promised he would beat
the virus and get this virus under
control case you forgot we've got the
videotape
i'm never going to raise the white flag
of survender we're going to beat this
virus and we're going to get it under
control i promise you
all right he was handed three vaccines
monoclonal antibody treatments and over
353
000 people now have died in 2021
that is more than the number of people
that died in 2020 when we knew far less
about covert 19 than we do now under
donald trump now if donald trump was in
office the coverage on fake news cnn the
three networks msdnc they'd be
apoplectic every single day there would
be you know the covert death counter you
know flashing across the screen all day
long how many people diagnosed how many
hospitalized how many dead
how come they do didn't do that when joe
biden's president
more people i'll say it again have died
this year in 2021 than died in 2020
and joe biden promised to get it under
control despite the lack of hysteria and
of course joe is in the media mob
protection program now this is a
disaster statistic for someone that
promised to beat coven 19 and had three
vaccines and therapeutics like
monoclonal antibodies but make no
mistake biden takes zero responsibility
instead he likes to blame you he loves
to scold you the american people then he
likes to play dr joe
and dr joe who only mentioned monoclonal
antibodies for the first time what about
three weeks ago like most liberals uh he
doesn't trust we the american people and
then by the way we don't have a shortage
of monoclonal antibodies but he just
decided to ration it because governors
like ron desantis set up the centers all
throughout florida because of
breakthrough cases and for the
unvaccinated and apparently they're
showing great results and anyway joe
clearly doesn't have the mental capacity
for good decisions so joe and his
liberal friends they play political
games they virtue signal they enact laws
that they themselves ignore in doing so
they actually create more vaccine
hesitancy not less just look at the
subject of face masks for example look
at this weekend joe biden dr jill biden
literally
bucked washington dc's indoor mask
mandate hey waltz through a restaurant
totally mask free a few months prior
member joe biden wearing a mask socially
distanced fully vaccinated outside of
jimmy carter's home then he goes inside
the home and the
96 year old former president takes off
the mask and there's no social
distancing so they can get pictures
remember it happened in new jersey with
governor phil murphy he enacted a mass
mandate for young children and then
partied hard at an indoor gala not a
mask in sight meanwhile a few days ago
squad member to leave bragging that she
only wears a mask when gop trackers are
present that's the only reason she wears
it take a look
thank you so much
this kind of mass hypocrisy has been
going on for months remember when nancy
pelosi remember she got her mass-free
haircut at that a closed down salon at
the pica covid oh how great they opened
just for her or gavin newsom attending a
large dinner party at a restaurant no
masks no social distancing when many
restaurants in california they were
closed for indoor dining many going
completely belly up bankrupt or what
about lori lightweight in chicago
attending a packed arena in chicago
completely massless for a wnba game and
thousands of other fans there as well
now the very same democrats they think
the rules don't apply to them they're
the ones though busy trying to force all
of you to get vaccinated in chicago up
to half the city's police force they may
soon be forced to go on leave or retire
if they don't comply with the city's
vaccine mandate now the city of chicago
they might actually deny benefits to
officers that choose to retire that are
due
this benefit by the way good luck
chicago with those lawsuits here's a
simple easy prediction the city of
chicago you will lose and lose badly in
court otherwise that would be called
licensed stealing because the cops who
you're threatening to steal their
pension from they earned every penny of
those pensions and they will get them
but get this mayor lori lightweight is
accusing unvaccinated officers of
inciting here it is the democrats
favorite word an insurrection take a
look
the police unions are not authorized to
strike it's in their collective
bargaining agreement it's a matter of
state law what we've seen from
the fraternal order of police and
particularly the leadership is a lot of
misinformation a lot of half-truths and
frankly flat out lies in order to induce
an insurrection
and we're not having that
sadly it's not only chicago police
departments all across the country they
are now mandating vaccines one officer
in washington state had this message to
governor inslee before signing off for
the final time take a listen
this is my final sign off
after 22 years of serving the citizens
of the state of washington
i'm being asked to leave because i am
dirty
i'd like to thank you guys i'd like to
thank the
citizens of yakima county as well as my
fellow officers within the valley
without you guys i would have been very
successful and you've kept me safe and
got me home to my family every night
thank you for that
um
[Music]
i wish i could say more but
this is it so
state 1034 this is the last time you'll
hear me in a state patrol car and
jansley can kiss my
all right
that sounds like uh the chant for
brandon anyway in the early months of
covert 19 police officers they didn't
have the option of staying home did they
they had no idea what the status health
status was of anybody they were coming
into contact with did they neither did
members of our military that risked
their lives for us they had no idea
either what about the doctors and nurses
and first responders
every single day they worked in a in a
petri dish of covet they were diving on
covet grenades to save lives every
single day
and they all bravely went to work they
all bravely faced the threat of covert
19 every single day and
many of them they contracted covet as a
result of trying to save other people's
lives and those with natural immunity
they're now being vilified they're now
going to be fired from their jobs
because they won't comply with biden's
mandate i thought what they said was
that if you got vaccinated you are
protecting yourself apparently not what
happened to biden's promise to allow an
alternate alternative solution like uh
testing unvaccinated workers instead of
firing them now biden of course lying
again he did the same thing he might
remember 13 days before he abandoned
americans in afghanistan he said we will
stay till every american's out
they're still behind enemy lines 65 days
later in the middle of a labor shortage
now americans are going to be forced
from their jobs we're going to lose
thousands of nurses and teachers and u.s
servicemen and women and police officers
over at espn they have a reporter
sideline reporter allison williams she
was forced to resign already in august
4.3 million american workers have quit
their jobs many are calling it the great
resignation and with biden's vaccine
mandates that's about to get so much
worse joe biden seemingly unconcerned he
has more important things to worry about
like walking and talking and and getting
to his afternoon nap every day is a
struggle for him and today was no
different we were one of the few in the
media that dare pointed out take a look
i tell you what
i would like to learn
again
it's monday joe monday night
now that's the person who's supposed to
lead us out of the at the shadow of a
global pandemic buckle up it will be a
bumpy ride